i feel like my mission is also to like
bring opportunity to the community as
well
because i lost so many friends that i
know if
they had the certain opportunities that
i had they pop
most likely would never
have been in the predicaments that they
were in when they did pass away
[Music]
what's up everybody my name is pastor
corey brooks and you know where i am
that's right i'm on the rooftop for 100
days from november the 20th till
february the 28th
staying in this tent bringing about
awareness to the violence in chicago but
most of all trying to raise as much
money as we possibly can to build a
center on this block that is called o
block o
named after a young man named od perry
who was shot and killed the gangs
adopted his name the o the letter o
start calling it o block well
i tell you every single day our goal is
to keep the o
but to name it opportunity block so
we're here today and i'm grateful with
my youngest son that's right my youngest
son who grew up in this neighborhood
that we're in and he's now a sophomore
at morehouse in atlanta georgia uh going
to school uh working on his degree
but
it's been tough
uh living in this neighborhood and i
wanted to share from his perspective
today on just how tough it's been and
and why some kids don't make it out so
his name is corey but we call him kobe
and so welcome to the show kobe
my rooftop revelations
welcome home i know you're away from
school and you're home but i wanted to
jump in and talk about um
living in the neighborhood how tough it
is you know we could have easily moved
out to the suburbs or something like
that but we decided to stay in the
neighborhood we decided to to be a part
of the neighborhood
sometimes i struggled with was that a
good decision or a bad decision because
you all encountered so much uh growing
up your brothers and sisters
um but how tough is growing up in this
neighborhood
um i'd say it's
kind of very tough to growing up in this
neighborhood because
it's not a lot of opportunity like as
far as like people outside of like
where i
like besides the church really
there's no real opportunity i see like
in the community for our people like
there's nowhere for them to like go
work on homework or go work on
like their craft like whatever they're
good at like they have nobody really
investing time into them except for
really the church and
it's like
they go through so much on both ends
like
[Music]
you know being tied in you know with
other things right and not growing up
having the proper
opportunities is
it kind of like is makes it tough say
yes tearing them you know yeah so so let
me ask you about that you know we talk
about i know we talk all the time about
creating opportunities and helping a lot
of the kids and helping your friends
um
but you lost a lot of friends too in the
neighborhood uh can you talk about that
for a minute
uh i know i know it's painful i know we
talk about the pain of it and i try to
urge you to go to counseling cause you
know
post traumatic stress but uh you know go
ahead
uh so
i can say i lost
about at
least that i can think of just right off
back
i lost six friends in the past five six
years
and
i can say it's been very traumatizing
but it's also made me part of who i am
today
and by that i'm saying like
they all like left
a certain lesson with me like
it it kind of molded me into like seeing
what my life was supposed to like what
my mission is almost like
i feel like my mission is also to like
bring opportunity to the community as
well
because i lost so many friends that i
know if
they had certain opportunities that i
had they probably
most likely would never
have been in the predicaments that they
were in when they did pass away yeah
because even though
you know you grew up in the same
neighborhood
you grew up in the household with your
mom your dad your brothers and sisters
a family unit and a lot of times
these kids unfortunately all they have
to depend on is their moms their dads
are sometimes locked up or
you know wherever and they it it's real
tough it's real difficult and nine times
out of ten the mom is always at work so
it's really
they depend on themselves and their
siblings it's like
they looking at each other to raise each
other instead of parents like yeah but i
didn't had a saying
no story you know what i want to ask you
one more quick question um about gangs
why is it that in our neighborhood that
you automatically
like i know for a fact you've never been
in a gang you're not in a gang you know
you're a great kid but you know you have
friends who
have that lifestyle you know because
they live in certain neighborhoods why
is it that even though you've never been
in a gang
that you automatically get associated
with a certain group of people
just because you live there why is that
what is that about
uh i say
from my standpoint and like from my
outside looking in i could say
is really like people involved
themselves in gangs because it's
protection almost like that's how they
look at it there's no real
providers out here for them is no real
protector so
they look to the guys on the block uh
the big brothers on the block
and that's their
that's their role models that's their
they that's what they run up beyond
that's all they see
so that's the road they tend to take and
other people associate you
because that's who you around and
even though you may never say
yeah i'm this
just because you hang with them or
like you from this certain area or
it's like
even if y'all blood it's just it's a lot
of certain things that could just tie
you in
and
it's not
i don't think that's right because
i don't think nobody should be like
judged about where they live at or
the circumstances they're labeled or
you feeling about the circumstances they
came from i feel like you shouldn't
judge a book by its cover like
you got to get to know people first you
you never know you might look at a kid
think he a gang banger but he might be
the smartest kid that you ever came
across like yeah
i really didn't met kids smarter than
guys i went to school at a private
school like
they just don't have the same
opportunity the same money to go to
these certain schools or to go to these
certain communities or like community
centers and like
it's not it's nobody really pouring any
opportunity or wisdom into them so
they kind of lose track and guidance
when growing up and they look towards
what they see and what's closest to them
and that's what's in the neighborhood so
last question so do you think a
community center will help in our
neighborhood and why
um i honestly think the community center
will be one of the biggest
things that'll happen to this community
not just the community in chicago really
right
i feel like well i know for a fact
it'll open up plenty jobs for
everybody in the community one
and
two i i know some of the things that
we're going to have in the community
center like a basketball court studios
dance studios
a theater auditorium like it's so many
carpentry classes
classes construction classes like
it's so many outlets
for kids to express themselves that we
didn't have growing up like we had bits
and pieces of it through the church but
the community center would be the
devoted to
really build an opportunity for
everybody in chicago more than just this
one community i feel like
i feel like it's a
it's not only like going to be a
blueprint for like other communities in
chicago but
country
not countries communities around the
country like
and eventually around the world
absolutely i believe that
so listen it it's always good being able
to talk to my son and share thoughts
with him and i'm so glad and so proud of
it being able to grow up in this
neighborhood
and not just grow up in the neighborhood
but
make good choices and
um and see and then try to be helpful to
some of his friends and that's what it's
all about i want to thank fox as always
for allowing me to share my rooftop
revelations and like i always say i'll
see you tomorrow peace
you